so let's talk about cultural
appropriation okay
over the weekend a high school girl just
a just a random high school girl not not
a public figure not a celebrity she
tweeted a picture of herself in her prom
dress and innocent enough she thought
right and she was tweeting it out to her
whatever a few hundred followers and she
was wearing I guess a Chinese style
dress and so a Chinese man Chinese
American man
it seems saw this tweet and he thought
well let me attack this high school girl
and yeah let me just do that let me try
to ruin her day in her week for no
reason so he screenshot of the tweet and
he sent his own tweet saying my culture
is not your damned prom dress my culture
is not your prom dress which I mean he's
right about that
she never claimed it was I don't think
she ever I didn't I didn't scroll
through all her tweets but I don't think
she ever said I'm wearing Chinese
culture today I'm wearing the entirety
of Chinese culture
today no I think she's just wearing a
dress just a dress is a dress you know
but his tweet attacking this girl cyber
bullying her basically got somehow
170,000 likes 170,000 and it sparked
this avalanche of criticism on this girl
and it started a conversation about
cultural appropriation and this goes
back to something I talked about last
week where you see now how everybody
who's on the internet now gets treated
like a public figure the everybody gets
this intense scrutiny over everything
they say and do and anyone at all no
matter who they are even if just some
sub 17 year old girl going to
anyone can can come under national
backlash for something and so this did I
guess this girl her number was up for
that so now ironically this this guy
Jeremy Lamb is his name and he's
pictured in his Twitter avatar wearing a
baseball cap board shorts and a t-shirt
none of which are traditional Chinese
garb I'm pretty sure in fact even his
name Jeremy is not Chinese that's most
certainly Western and I according to an
internet search that I just did a minute
ago the mo just for an example okay the
most popular name the most popular male
name in China right now is Jong way now
the reason I bring it up is is can you
imagine if some lily-white American
parents who wanted to be trendy you know
if they had a baby boy and they named
him Zhang Wei and they sent out a tweet
or something with a picture of their of
their extremely white baby saying oh my
little Jong Way was born eight pounds
nine ounces you know what happened they
would come under again intense national
backlash how dare you appropriate
Chinese culture by giving him a Chinese
name but Jeremy has appropriated a
Western name he's appropriated an entire
Western wardrobe I mean everything from
his hat right down those shoes okay all
of it is Western and really if if we're
gonna talk about appropriation if we're
gonna get into the appropriation
discussion and if we're gonna get into
this game where we say okay you're not
allowed to use anything or wear anything
that doesn't originate with your culture
if we're doing that it's not gonna work
out too well for non-westerners because
first of all by the rules of this game
if the rules were applied evenly by the
rules of the game if you're a non
Western if you are if you are of
non-western heritage first of all you
need to stop doing what you're doing at
this exact moment stop doing it go right
now go away because you can't computers
phones any kind of phone these are all
Western inventions and you can't use
them it's appropriation cars airplanes
much of modern medicine antibiotics most
of the appliances that you have in your
kitchen dishwasher refrigerator all that
you can't use that electricity
lightbulbs movies TV photography
democracy ok air conditioning I could go
on and on and on and I haven't even
gotten to clothing yet jeans ball caps
t-shirts sneakers can't wear those under
these rules can't wear them this is why
cultural appropriation is utter nonsense
one of the reasons anyway because it
puts cultures into these boxes and it
doesn't permit cross over and it denies
the very diversity that the left
pretends to value above everything else
they say we let you know diversity is
the best thing in the world and yet
they're the ones saying no you can't
have that that belongs to the other
culture you got to stick with your own
cultures separate-but-equal called equal
cultures ok stay separate stay
segregated that's what they're saying or
or I should say let me let me clarify
back up for a minute it denies you the
the right to cross over into another box
if you're white so it's a one-way ticket
here basically if it tells White's to
stay in their box and never go outside
of it but people of other races and
ethnicities they can come into our box
all they want they can take what they
want browse around you know look around
take this they take a sneaker put on a
ball cap use some air conditioning take
a you know take a flight back and forth
from I mean they can do whatever they
want but for us we have to stay right
here in this box and we can never go and
do anything outside of it so the double
stand the double standard is so blatant
just so extremely blatant and
in-your-face and and and they just just
so unashamed is this shameless I should
say is this double standard that it's
almost shocking as a custom as we all
are to the double standard it almost
succeeds in shocking but the real double
standard
the real double standard with this
appropriation stuff has nothing to do
with culture or race or anything like
that
the thing is that because there is one
place there is one place there's one
area where where real live honest-to-god
appropriation actually does occur
harmful degrading demeaning
appropriation that is happening but the
one place where it actually happens the
one place where appropriation actually
happens and is actually harmful and is
actually offensive in degrading that's
the one place where the left celebrates
it and of course I'm talking about men
who appropriate womanhood by pretending
to be women that is the one actual real
example of appropriation and it's the
one place where the left not it's not
that they look the other way they
actually applaud it and say yeah it's
brave it's inspiring it's beautiful but
here is real appropriation here's a man
who has reduced femininity to a
caricature to a cartoon basically and he
says he has an urge to wear dresses and
to wear high heels and to wear lipstick
and that this urge somehow indicates
that he's really a woman inside by
intruding on womanhood he turns
womanhood into nothing more than a
fashion choice essentially he empties it
of all of its substance he says that a
woman's body what goes on inside her
what goes
inside her mind all of it what goes on
inside her soul her ability to create
human beings and to and to you know
Harbor them in inside her body and to
nourish them with her body all of that
ok those things that are really
authentically uniquely fantastically
beautifully woman those things none of
that all those things don't matter none
of that matters according to the new way
of looking at it because in order for
the man to take part in womanhood well
then we've got a strip womanhood of all
the things that are unique to it because
he can't he can't he can't have any part
of that he can be a woman he says
without any of that so none of that
matters as long as he puts on a dress
and maybe he changes his name and he
grows his hair out and maybe he gets
implants or something and he mutilates
his genitals if he does all that well
now he's a woman all the rest of the
stuff that used to be the territory the
the of women it doesn't matter so so see
here we have the actual consequences of
appropriation that the left worries will
happen with cultural appropriation here
we have it actually happening because
their arguments what is their argument
against a white girl wearing a Chinese
prom dress what's their argument against
what why are they worried about it
what's the big deal well according to
them by wearing the dress she reduces
Chinese culture to a fad and to a
novelty she takes part in it she
benefits from it she borrows its beauty
she kind of like steals it without
understanding it and thus she makes it
into something superficial and hollow
and just like something to parade around
like a costume basically she turns she
Chinese culture into a into a costume
that's the argument now that doesn't
really happen when a white person wears
a Chinese dress or when a white person I
don't know whatever else gets them
accused of a probe listens to Beyonce or
something like that that's not that that
doesn't that doesn't do any harm to
anybody it doesn't cheapen Chinese
culture and black culture it doesn't
because cultures intermingle they blend
and fashions and styles change and so
that's there's this exchange between
cultures that goes on and that used to
be what the left
you know celebrated and said we should
be doing is is this intermingling and
exchange of cultures but womanhood and
manhood on the other hand are absolutes
they are poles okay they're like North
and South Poles and when men come in and
they blur those lines they really do
blur the lines that give women their
identity because this is what the fun in
order to have an identity
there must be lines of distinction and
it used to be and it still is
scientifically but our culture doesn't
recognize it anymore it used to be that
we all recognized that the there were
certain lines that defined a woman and
those lines were really obvious among
them as I said she can create a person
okay she could conceive a person within
her and bring that human being into the
world me this is incredible
ability it's such an incredible power
that she has the fate of all human
civilization rests on the woman because
we need the woman to propagate
civilization of course the woman needs
the man to take part in that but but the
woman has has this very essential role
of actually harboring the child bringing
the
and then the child even when he's born
you know
after he's born the child has a real
physical need for the mother
technically the child doesn't even need
the man I mean kids do need their
fathers don't get me wrong but a newborn
child has a physical need for the mother
the newborn won't even notice his dad
for like several months believe me I've
had three he needs his mother so there's
this that that that motherly maternal
connection you know and it's just that
those were the things that used to
define womanhood but we've torn down
those lines we've we've we've destroyed
them we've obliterated them for the sake
of these cross-dressing men and so the
LGBT Lobby has actually done to
womanhood what the left says this girl
did to Chinese culture but the girl in
the Chinese prom dress is villainized a
man in a prom dress is canonized the
girl in the dress is accused of turning
Chinese culture into nothing but a dress
the man in the dress actually has turned
womanhood into nothing but a dress he's
actually done it at least in the eyes of
society yet he gives what gets away with
it it's incredible all of this talk
about appropriation here it is it's
actually happening let's talk about that
and it's doing real harm to women it's
part of the reason why now you got to
worry about your about your you know
your your daughter ending up in a locker
room or in a in a bathroom with a man
because of this men have come in and
appropriated woman I think they've
they've even taken their bathrooms from
them in their their locker rooms their
private intimate spaces men have come in
and taken I should specify the LGBTQ
camp
has come in and taken so how is this
happening how is it how is this being
allowed to happen well the answer is
it's as I've explained in the past the
left has what I call a victim pyramid or
a victim hierarchy now we know that
victimization is currency on the Left
victim the victimization is power on the
left and whoever is the the most
victimized victim of all well they're
going to have the most power they can do
whatever they want and they can't be
questioned so there's this jockeying for
a position among the various
demographics on the Left who can be the
most victimized and there's always this
competition but who's the most oppressed
who's the most person who's the most
bullied and so on and so forth
right now the LGBT folks are at the very
top of the victim of the victim
hierarchy there all the way at the top
they've ascended to the peak and this is
a big moment for them whether they're
here at the top and they're reaping all
the benefits and what it means is that
they can do whatever they want and
nobody can criticize them and really the
transgenders have even ascended to the
top of the top which is what well you
know now you find even I I saw some
headline on Twitter recently that gay
men are being told that they they can't
dress as drag queens anymore because I
think oh my gosh just try to wrap your
head around this the new thing that I
that I've seen is that gay men cannot
dress like drag queens because they're
appropriating from transgenders okay
there
that's what now it's men now men in
dresses are appropriating from other men
and dresses so anyway so the
transgenders have ascended all the way
to the top of the top of the top and
they can do whatever they want and no
one could criticize them because they're
the most victimized of all for some you
know for my
observations of studying the left it
seems to me and they're like I said
there's a jockeying for position and
kind of it's sort of this game of
thrones that goes on but right now
transgenders at the top and then the
rest of the lgbtq XYZ squad they're
there right underneath them and then
racial minorities are right below them
and then women women are actually kind
of at the bottom right now on the left
in terms of the victim hierarchy which
is why even after all the the work that
feminists have done after all the you
know feminists have especially modern
feminists they spent a lot of time
finding persecution where it doesn't
actually exist they find rape culture
where it doesn't exist but meanwhile
that you've got actual dudes walking
into their bathrooms and their locker
rooms and they're not allowed to
complain about that they can complain
about man spreading on the subway they
can complain about anything else but
they can't complain about that they
basically been told shut your mouth and
go with the program and for the most
part on the left and the feminist most
of them do they're put in their place by
the LGBT and so they just go along with
it so that's why you know that's how
we've ended up in this really absurd
situation and I'm sort of waiting and
it's happened a little bit there's been
a few examples of it there have been a
few liberal feminists who have sort of
very gingerly ventured into the
territory of kind of criticizing the
transgender thing but I'm waiting for
the moment when the feminists really
just gets fed up with it
and they say you know what no we're not
going to tolerate this anymore
I mean they've spent all this time
telling men that you're not even allowed
to have opinions about women's issues if
you don't have a uterus that's been
their refrain for decades they've said
no uterus no opinion and now they've got
to sit there and just deal with it while
men
not only have opinions about women but
actually become women without uterus and
they're not elected so eventually I
think the feminists are going to get fed
up of it with it and there's gonna be a
full-on civil war on the left over this
issue but as it stands right now men can
appropriate all they want and it's the
one kind of appropriation that the left
never says anything about and that is
the real reason why appropriation is
nonsense all right have a great day
everyone Godspeed